انها ثامنه بتوقيت جرينتش الحادي عشر
بتوقيت الرياضه وهذه اخبار الساعه
في قمه المناخ تحذيرات من هلاك البشر
ومبادراته لانقاذ الارض والسعوديه تخصص
مليارين ونصف من الدولارات لشرق اوسط اخضر
في اول مقابله له مع قناه العربيه ريشي
سوناك يؤكد للعربيه ان ايران تعقد الوضع
بسلوكها في الداخل
في اوكرانيا الحرب كر وفر والمفاوضات مد
وجزر روسيا تتهم كياف برفض الحوار
والاخيره تنفي لكن بشروط
قبل الاقتراع والفرز الجمهوريون يشككون في
نتائج الانتخابات النصفيه وحكام الولايات
يضعون خطه استباقيه
[موسيقى]
وسعتم اوقاتنا اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه
اما النجاه او الهلاك هذا كان العنوان
الابرز في قمه المناخ المنعقده في شرم
الشيخ اليوم التي توافد اليها قاده العالم
لبحث اكبر خطر يهدد البشريه التغير
المناخي الجميع على خطوره الازمه المناخيه
واثارها الكارثيه على البشر والارض وهنا
يكمن التحدي سرعه التحرك التعاون والجهه
المشترك من الجميع فالوقت يداهمنا والهدف
الاول والاهم خفض درجه حراره كوكب لاننا
في معركه بقاء اما ننجو معا او تقودنا
للهلاك
[موسيقى]
خلال قمه المناخ وجه الامين العام للامم
المتحده تحضيرا جديده
ان مشكله المناخ تمثل معركه خطيره ضد
الانسانيه
فولايت
في مواجهه التغير المناخي ونحن نخسر
ارتفاع درجات الحراره حول العالم مستمر
والخطر كبيره الحرب في اوكرانيا والصراعات
واعمال العنف القت بظلالها على العالم يجب
ان لا نركز فقط على حل الصراعات وننسى
مشكله المناخ لان المناخ يمثل تحديا كبيرا
لنا الفوضى المناخيه هي السبب الرئيس في
الصراعات العالميه الحرب على البيئه
انتهاك خطير لحقوق الانسان هناك تحذيرات
علميه من حقيقه ارتفاع درجات الحراره ما
يعني اننا نقترب من نقطه لا عوده
ومن شرم الشيخ اطلق ولي العهد السعودي
الامير محمد بن سلمان مبادره الشرق الاوسط
الاخضر واعلن ان المملكه ستخصص 2.5 مليار
دولار من اجل مبادره خضراء بالشرق الاوسط
على مدار السنوات العشر القادمه وستستضيف
مقرها الرئيسي واكدا في الوقت ذاته على
استهداف السعوديه الوصول الى الحياد
الصفري في عام 2050
تاكيدا هالزمن المملكه بجهوده بجهود
الاسلاميه
مليون دولار دعمه لمشروعاتها المبادره
والميزانيه الامانه العامه على مدى عشر
سنوات القادمه
للوصول الحياد الصفري الانبعاثات غاز
الاحتباس الحراري بحلول عام 20 50 من خلال
نهج الاقتصاد الدائري الكربون اللي يكون
من اوائل الصناديق الثروه السياديه عالميا
والاول في منطقه الشرق الاوسط في استهدافه
وصول الحياه الصفري بحلول عام 20 50 مما
يعزز دور الصندوق كلاعب الرئيسيه في دعم
الجهود العالميه في مواجهه التحديات
المناخ
كما اكد ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن
سلمان على ان المملكه تسعى الى ان تمثل
الطاقه المتجدده 50% من الاستهلاك في عام
مبادره السعوديه الخضراء لخفض الانبعاثات
باكثر من
278,000,000 طن مكافئ ثاني اكسيد الكربون
بحلول 20 30 من خلال تطبيق منهج الاقتصاد
الدائري الكربون والاطلاق عديده
والمبادرات الاخرى منها منصه التعاون
الدوليه لتطبيق هذا النهج وصندوق استثماري
اقليمي مخصصه لتمويل تقنيات الاقتصاد
الدائره الكربون مبادره الحلول والوقود
النظيف من اجل توفير الغذاء
كما قامت المملكه بتسريع اوتيله تطوير
وتبني التقنيات ومصادر الطاقه النظيفه
المتمثله باستخدام الطاقه المتجدده بهدف
اداره انبعاثات ومن موارد الهيدروكربونيه
وابراز هذه الخطوه
يمثل يتمثل في تتويج مزيج الطاقه المستخدم
في توليد الكهرباء في المملكه بحيث يتم
انتاج 50% من الكهرباء داخل المملكه
بالاعتماد على مصادر الطاقه متجدده بحلول
20 30
[موسيقى]
معنى من مقر انعقاد بقيمه المناخ في شرم
الشيخ مراسل العربيه احمد عثمان احمد اهلا
بك معنا ابدا معك من مبادره الامير محمد
بن سلمان للشرق الاوسط الاخضر ما هو صدى
ما اعلنه الامير محمد بن سلمان بين
المشاركين في قمه المناخ
نعم صهيب مساء الخير بالفعل ربما بعد
اطلاقه هذه المبادره من خلال ومن خلال
الكلمات التي الكلمه التي القاها الامير
محمد بن سلمان ولي العهد وايضا الكلمات
التي جاءت تعقيبا على ما تراحه الامير
محمد من قبل القاده العرب المشاركين
استطيع ان اقول بان كان صدى هذه المبادره
قويه جدا فيما يتعلق بما قدمته المملكه من
خلال شهر اكتوبر الماضي من خلال النسخه
الاولى لهذه المبادره ومن خلال ما طرحه
الامير محمد اليوم عن ما سيتلو خلال
المرحله المقبله سواء فيما يتعلق بالدعم
المادي لهذه المبادره مبادره الشرق الاوسط
الاخضر واتساع رقاعتها وايضا فيما يتعلق
التي الجهود التي وعد الامير محمد بها
بالوصول الى همم الصفريه غازات الانبعاثات
الحراريه الى عام 2050 نعم ربما كانت هذه
هي من اهم المشاهد التي جرت اليوم
بالتاكيد كان هناك الكثير من ال- ال- صحيح
صدى الايجابي لما طرح- لما تم طرحه من
خلال هذه المباراه ولن السعوديه والشرق
الاوسط جزء من هذا العالم ومن هذا الكوكب
المشاكل البيئيه مشتركه ومسؤوليه الجميع
اهم ما طرح من حلول للتغير المناخي في هذا
اليوم في اجتماع القاده احمد
نعم صهيب ربما هذه النقطه تحديدا كانت من
خلال الكلمات التي جاءت على السنه القاده
اغلب من تحدثه من الدول الصناعيه الكبرى
اكدوا بانه سيكون هناك زياده او تحدث بان
هناك دعما ماديا سيقدم من ميزانيات هذه
الدول للمشاركه هذه الوعود ربما جاء
التطبيقا لما تم تاكيده في الامس بانه
سيكون هناك ما يطلق عليه بالتمويل او
التعويضات بعد يتحدث عن ارقام ب 100 مليار
دولار هناك الكثير من المبادرات التي قدمت
بشكل احادي فيما يتعلق بمشاريعه مبادرات
لتقليس هذه الاضرار على الدول الجنوب او
الدول المتضرره او الدول الفقيره بشكل عام
احمد عثمان مباشره من خدمه 27 من شرم
الشيخ شكرا جزيلا
[موسيقى]
قد يكون تحديد التغير المناخيه للبشر هو
العنوان الابرز لتداعياته الحاليه
والمستقبليه لكنه لا يقل اهميه عن الخسائر
التي يتسبب فيها هذا تغير المناخي فتغير
المناخي مشاهدينا يكلف مختلف اقتصادات
العالم ثمنا باهظا فعلى مدى العقد الماضي
عده الكوارث المتعلقه بالطقس والمناخ
والمياه الى تكبد العالم خسائر تتجاوز 200
مليون دولار في اليوم خلال ال50 عاما
الماضيه وفقا لارقام مع هذه شركه التامين
سويس ار 8 نفس المؤسسه قالت ان الكوارث
الطبيعيه الناجمه بالدرجه الاولى عن
التغير المناخي تتسبب في خسائر بنحو فصل
3% من الناتج المحليه العالمي سنويه كما
ان الكلفه مرشحه للارتفاع في السنوات
المقبله وفقا لمؤسست دوله التي توقعت ان
يتكمل الاقتصاد العالمي خسائر تصل الى مئه
وثمانيه تريليون دولار عند حلول لسنه 2070
في حال وصلت درجات الحراره ارتفاع
معنى من باريس دكتور بدوي الرهبان
المستشار لدى اليونسكو والامم المتحده
لشؤون المناخ والمستشار الدولي للكوارث
الطبيعيه والتغير المناخي دكتور اهلا بكم
معنا بدايتها هل انت متفائل ان قيمه
المناخ في شرم الشيخ قد تخرج بحلول
التصدي لتغير المناخي
على كل حال ان الكلمات التي
سمعناها اليوم من قاده الدول ومن امين عام
ومتحده تشير الى ان قاده الدول اصغر
للتحذيرات والانذارات التي تواصل الامم
المتحده وخاصه الامين العام
بانذار بها منذ عده شهور وخاصه منذ الصيف
الماضي اذا نامل ان هذه التصريحات سوف
تترجم فعليا بالتزامات وباجراءاتهم على
الارض مثلا همم مبادره الشرق الاوسط
الخضراء هي تستجيب جهاز النوع من النداءات
يعني اجراءات على الارض شراكات على
المستوى الاقليم ان كان في الدول الشرق
الاوسط او في افريقيا او في امريكا
الجنوبيه نريد مبادرات واجراءات على الارض
لكي نخفض من جهه
الانبعاثات للغازات الدفيئه التي هي سبب
انت باسل الحراري وتغير المناخ من جهه ومن
جهه ثانيه لكي نتكيف ونجعل مدننا وبلداتنا
وكرانا يستطيعون ان يهتموا من العواصف من
الفيضانات من السيول من موجات الحر ومن
حرائق الغابات هذه هي الاجراءات التي هي
مطلوبه لن تحصل كل الاجراءات في مؤتمر شرم
الشيخ ولكن نامل ان عنوان شرم الشيخ الذي
هو الانتقال الى الاجراءات والتفعيل
الالتزامات ان هذا سوف يقر به المؤتمر هذه
هي النتيجه التي تكون نجاحا للمؤتمر اذا
ما حصلت نعم يجري الحديث كذلك على ايجاد
اليه ما لكي همم تعوض الدول الغنيه الدول
الفقيره بسبب اثار التغير المناخي راينا
مثلا في السنه همم الحاليه تضرر الباكستان
بشكل كبير من الفيضانات هل برايك كذ هذا
همم يمكن ان يتم التوصل له والايفاء بهذه
التعاهدات الماليه
ان ايجاد اليات هو حيوي وضروري ونعتقد ان
في شرم الشيخ سوف يكون هناك اعلان عن
مبادره هامه على هامش المؤتمر التي هي
تقتضي بان بحلول عام 2030 كل الدول سوف
تكون مجهزه بانظمه للانذار المبكر انذار
المبكر للفياضانات للسيول للعواصف لموجات
الحرب عندما يكون هناك انظمه انذار مبكر
يستطيع المواطنون ان يستعدوا لوصول
الكارثه يستعدوا
بحمايه اولادهم بحمايه منازلهم بحمايه
بلداتهم بتوعيه المدارس عندما نكون عندنا
خمسه ايام استباك نستطيع ان نحمله هذا
للاسف لم يكون موجود في الباكستان في
الصيف الماضي للاسف شكرا
شكرا جزيلا لكم دكتور بدوي الرحباني
المستشار لدى اليونسكو للامم المتحده
للشؤون المناخ والمستشار الدولي للكوارث
الطبيعيه والتغير المناخي كنت معنا من
باريس
[موسيقى]
ايضا في شرم الشيخ وفي اول مقابله مع
وسيله اعلاميه عربيه قال رئيس الوزراء
البريطاني ريشي سوناك في مقابله مع
العربيه ان ايران رفضت في مارس الماضيه
التي فاق النووي والوضع اصبح اكثر صعوبه
بسبب قمع النظام للمتظاهرين وافعال ايران
المزعزع للاستقرار هناك قال ان العلاقات
بين بريطانيا ودول مجلس التعاون الخليجي
مهمه وتاريخيه واكد انه يتطلعوا الى اخذها
الى الامام وتطويرها خصوصا في مجال
الاقتصاد والتجاره
مستر بن
باسمك سناب
برجراف
الحديث اكثر معنا من لندن راتب سليمان
العضو السابق في حزب المحافظين اهلا بك
معنا بدايه اسالك عن مقله ريشي سوناك في
هذه المقابله الاولى له مع قناه عربيه مع
قناتنا مع العربيه تحدث عن العلاقات بين
بريطانيا ودول الخليج كيف ترى تطور هذه
العلاقه او ما الذي سيتغير في العلاقه
البريطانيه الخليجيه مع رئاسه ريشيسومات
للحكومه
مساء الخير لكم وللمشاهدين الاعزاء همم
الان سيحاول قدر الامكان همم ربط علاقاته
مع الدول العربيه اجمالا وخاصه دول الخليج
لان دول الخليج لها علاقات
اقتصاديه وعلاقات سياسيه وعلاقات اخرى مع
بريطانيا منذ
عشرات السنين هذه العلاقات دوما قويه
ولها جذور سابقه جميع الحكومات او جميع
همم
جميع رؤساء الوزراء الذين سبقوا هناك كانت
لهم علاقات جيده مع دول الخليج ومع الدول
العربيه كذلك طيب احاديث شريفه هناك عن
الوضع في ايران كان في ما يتعلق بالاتفاق
نووي وان كان التظاهرات كذلك التي عقدت
الوضع كما كما قال كذلك برايك كيف
ريشي سوناك مع الملف الايراني
سيتعامل كما تتعامل همم الدول الاخرى
الدول الاوروبيه وامريكا سيكون موقف
بريطانيا كما تقف الدول الاخرى سيكون هناك
عقوبات على ايران وسيكون هناك همم نقاش
همم اخر همم حول الملف النووي بين الدول
الاوروبيه وامريكا وبريطانيا اتوقع اا ال-
اا
البريطانيا وامريكا لها قرار واحد يعني
همم سيكون قرارهم بانه لا يوجد حتى الان
اتفاق نووي مع ايران لان ايران دوما خالفت
جميع الشروط التي همم
اتفقوا عليها سابقا لذلك لا اتوقع بانه
سيكون هناك اتفاق نووي في الوقت الحاضر
وخاصه همم
التي تقوم بها الان همم الشعب الهمم
الايراني يقوم بالمظاهرات يطالب بالحقوق
ويطالب بالحياه الكريمه والحريه همم اتوقع
بان الحكومه البريطانيه سيكون موقفها كما
موقف الدول الاخرى الاوروبيه والامريكيه
طيب في ما يتعلق بالظروف الحاليه والظروف
التي تواجهها بريطانيا واوروبا بشكل عام
بارتفاع التضخم وهمم وارتفاع اسعار الطاقه
كذلك همم كيف يمكن همم ان يكون هناك ربما
علاقه مختلفه الان خاصه مع دول الخليج هو
مع السعوديه بالتحديد يمكن ان تكون همم
ذات منفعه للطرفين بشكل مختلف عن سابق
العلاقه بينهما
اتوقع هذا سيحصل قريبا يعني الان الدول
بحاجه لبعضها البعض
وخاصه الدول الاوروبيه
وبريطانيا بحاجه الى الدول العربيه لان
الدول العربيه هي الدول الاولى بالتصدير
الطاقه
والنفط والغاز لذلك الان الدول الاوروبيه
جميعها بحاجه الى الدول العربيه وتحتاج
الغاز وتحتاج الطاقه
اتوقع بان العلاقات ستكون جيده وستتحسن
الى الافضل
وعشش هناك لديه ااا
سياسه مختلفه اختلافا كبيرا عن سابقه همم
عقله منفتح ويحاول ان يبني علاقات جيده مع
اكثر الدول وخاصه الدول العربيه
شكرا جزيلا لكم من لندن راتب ااا سليمان
انتم العضو السابق في حزب المحافظين
[موسيقى]
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه الذي اربك
المغردين يدخل على خط الانتخابات
الامريكيه ليشتت الناخبين
اهلا بكم من جديد الحرب في اوكرانيا بين
مد وجزر فتره تلوح في الافق مؤشرات على
امكانيه اللجوء الى طاوله المفاوضات وتاره
اخرى تظهر معطيات تؤكد ان الصراع على زال
مستمرا في اخر التكهنات
جورنال ان الغربه لا يرى غراء خيارا سوى
الاستمرار في دعم اوكرانيا مرجعت ان السبب
الى قرارات الرئيس
الذي اقنعه تصعيده معظم الدول الغربيه
بعدم وجود اي احتمال لاجراء محادثات سلام
قريبا
اه صحيفه عزيزه كلامها بتصريحات
دبلوماسيين غربيين مطلعين اكدوا ان واشنطن
وحلفائها لا يرون سوى احتماليه ضئيله
للتوصل الى نهايه تفوضيه للحرب في
اوكرانيا وسردت الصحيفه مجموعه من الاسباب
التي تجعل الخطوه الدبلوماسيه مستبعده في
الوقت الراهن اولها المعارك المستمره على
ارض الميدان سنان المعركه الوشيكه في
خرسون ثانيا الاستهداف الروسيه المتواصل
لمحطات طاقه الاوكرانيه ما ادى الى انقطاع
الكهربائي في العديد من المناطق وثالثها
ضم روسيا لاربعه اخالين في اوكرانيا
لكن وبعد ان كشفت صحيفه وسط الجورنال ان
مستشار الامن القومي جيكسوليفان اجرا
محادثات لم يعلن عنها مع كبار المسؤولين
الروس على امل تقليل المخاطر في اوكرانيا
التي ربما تصل الى حد النزاع النووي ردت
روسيا على تلك الانباء ورفضت التعليق في
مقال المتحدث باسم الكرملينن ان روسيا
منفتحه على المحادثات لكن كيف هي من ترفض
اجراءات تفاوض
وفي المقابل اوكرانيا رده ونفتت ما تدعيه
روسيا وافاد احد كبار المستشارين رئيس
الاوكراني على انك لم ترفض قط التفاوض مع
موسكو انها مستعده لاجراء محادثات مع رئيس
روسيا المستقبليه ولكن ليس الرئيس الحليم
العظيم الفوتن وكتب المستشار التابع
للرئيس الاوكرانيه ام ميخائيو بده اياك
على حساب الرسميه على تويتر ان اوكرانيا
لم ترفض التفاوض فقط وان موقفها من
التفاوض معروف ومعلن مشددا على ان روسيا
ينبغي عليها ان تسحب قواتها من اوكرانيا
اولا
معنى من كياب يوري ساك مستشار وزير الدفاع
الاوكراني سيد يريد هل تعتقد ان الغرب
بقياده الولايات المتحده يريد دفع
اوكرانيا لانهاء هذه الحرب
القوه الغربيه
وكما سمعنا في اكثر من من مناسبه من قبل
القياده العسكريه وسياسيه بان بلدنا هي
تتمتعوا بسيادتها ولنا حريه القرار في
مساله التوجه للتفاوض من عدمه وكنا واضحين
بهذا الامر بشان شروط المتعلقه
الشرط الاول هو الانسحاب الكامل لكافه
القوات الروسيه
هو نظرا
لوجود القياده الحاليه في روسيا فمن غير
المرجح ان تتم قبول هذه الشروط لهذا نقول
فان المفاوضات قد تكون ضربا من المستحيل
فهناك جمله من العوائق فنحن لدينا شروط
غير قابله للتفاوض يجب ان تكون في بدايه
هذه العمليه وهذا ما قلنا باننا نستطيع ان
نقوم باجراء هذه المفاوضات مع رئيس
المستقبل في روسيا
الشروط الاوكرانيه هي ضرب من دروب
المستحيلات يعني انتم تطالبون بالتفاوض مع
رئيس اخر غير الرئيس عبد العظيم وانت عوده
روسيا
وتسلم كل الاراضي التي سيطرت عليها الى
اوكرانيا الا يوجد حل اخر ربما في منتصف
الطريق بين الجانبين من اجل همم حقن
الدماء وايقاف هذه الحرب
باقول لك زي مزه بتاع الصوت
في العالم يقولون بانه من المستحيل ان
تقوم لاوكران ان تستطيع اوكرانيا ان تقاوم
ثاني اكبر جيش في العالم وقد قمنا بتحقيق
هذه المعجزه لابد لنا ان نقوم باستعاده
بكافه اراضينا والحفاظ على سيادتها
وسلامتها وهذا امر معترف به في دوليا ونحن
لن نتنازل عن شبرا من بلادنا للغزات
والعالم كله يتفهم والاسره الدوليه ايضا
تقف معنا
هذه حرب عدائيه ويجب ان لا نسمعها لروسيا
ان تمر من هذه من هذه الحرب دون عقابه ان
تحتفظ بالمناطق التي قامت بضمها بشكل
صاروخ
للاعراف الدوليه هذا امر غير مقبول
ومستحيل
هو معركه خيرسون المرتبه
راحت ناقص شويه
الامور تعد صعبه في اجزاء مختلفه من
الجبهات بما في ذلك في منطقه خرسون وكذلك
ايضا هناك معارك مستعره في الشرق مثل ضخم
وتواصله في نياسكو
انها ظروف
تتسموا بالدينانيه في الخطوط الاماميه
والجيش الاوكرانيه يفعلوا ما بوسع من اجل
الاستمرار في عملياتنا الهجوميه المضاده
وسوف نقوم بتحرير خيرسون بكل تاكيد وهي
مساله وقت هو مساله مساعده دوليه ولكن سيد
جوري هناك من يرى بان يعني معركه خيرسون
ستكون اخر المعارك في الحرب الاوكرانيه هل
هذه مجرد تكه هناك ام ربما ستكون هي
المعركه الاعنف التي بعدها
سيذهب الجميع الى طاوله المفاوضات
شو رايك
انظر الى الامور التي تجري في خرسه ويصعب
علينا ان نفهم المنطقه الروسي فهم
قاموا بترحيل اكثر من من سبعه الاف لشخص
اوكرا الى خير
الاثار من متاحف كثيره ومواد قيمه هذا جزء
من الخارصون في الجانب الايمن من نهر
لقيامه روسيا
بهذا التصرف
بعمليات المتداوله لو كانوا يتحللون
بالحكمه فعليه من الاستسلام شكرا جزيلا لك
مستشار وزير الدفاع الاوكراني مباشره
[موسيقى]
في تصريحات خاصه للعربيه قالت رئيسه وزراء
الاساسيه وراء انضمام بلادها والسويد ايضا
الى حلف الناتو هو الخوف من وقوع هجوم
الروسيه كما حصل في اوكرانيا
بحاجه حمايه الماده الخامسه نريد ان نضمن
ان روسيا لن تدخل حدودنا بالرغم من انه لا
تهديدات الان الا اننا نريد ضمان ان روسيا
لن تهددنا وان الدول الاعضاء الاخرى سترسل
الدعوه في حال وقوع اي هجوم علينا لم نكن
لنصل الى هذه المرحله من القلق لولا
الهجوم الروسي على اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
نذهب الى ايران الان لم يكتفي النظام
بالقتل والتعذيب والاعتقال لقمع
الاحتجاجات بل يعد لخطه لقمعا اعنف هذا
منشره اكثر من 120 استاذا من جامعه الامير
كبير للتكنولوجيا في رساله حذروا فيها من
خطه تعدها السلطات الحكوميه للتعامل بقسوه
مع الطلاب اكده ان زياده قمع الطلاب يخالف
ما وصفوه بالمصلحه العامه والمنطق كما انه
غير لائق ويؤجج للاحتجاجات وسيجعل البلاد
في وضعنا اصوات
ومع استمرار حمله القمع التي يمارسها
النظام الايراني ضد المحتاجين لجا
الاوروبيون الى العقوبات ضد طهران بعد
ايام على اعلان الاتحاد الاوروبي فرضى
حزمه جديده قريبا على المسؤولين المتورطين
في قمع الاحتجاجات اكد المانيا اليوم ان
العمل جاري بالفعل على فرض العقوبات خصوصا
على الحرس الثوري لدوره في عمليات قمع
المتظاهرين وهذه العقوبات التي يجري
اعدادها الان لن تكون الاولى منذ لاعب
احتجاجات في ايران حيث فرض الاتحاد
الاوروبي نهايه اكتوبر الماضي عقوبات ضد
مسؤولين ايرانيين بينهم قائد شرطه الاخلاق
وكانت وزيره الخارجيه الالمانيه
الاسبوع الماضي ان برلين و الاتحاد
الاوروبيه ادراج الحرس الثوري في قوائم
الارهاب
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
من ايران الى امريكا الانتخابات النصفيه
القادمه
ستجدد فيها نصف مقاعد الكونجرس بل هي
اختبار للديمقراطيه في الولايات المتحده
فتداعيات تشكيله الرئيس الامريكي السابق
بنتائج الانتخابات الرئاسيه الماضيه لا
تزال تلقي بظلالها على المشهد السياسيه في
البلاد 12
لا يزالون غير متاكدين مما اذا كان
بامكانهم الايمان بالعمليه الانتخابيه
الاكثر من ذلك فان شبح التشكيك في
الانتخابات واي احتمال اعمال عنف دفع
حكومه مختلفه في الولايات المتحده الى وضع
خطه استفاقيه من خلال تعزيزات من الشرطه
لحمايه المباني التي سيتم فيها فرز
الاصوات
وكشفت الصحيفه تزايد الشقوق المواطنين في
عدم دقه عمليه فرز اصوات الناخبين فذلك
منذ الانتخابات الرئاسيه الاخيره وقالت
الصحيفه في استطلاع عن اجرته بشراكه مع اي
بي سي ان ثلث الاشخاص الذين تم استجوابهم
ليست لديهم ثقه في دقه عمليه الفرس
هذا ولا زالت فكره عدم الثقه في
الانتخابات تجد مروجين لها اولهم مع رئيس
الجمهوريه السابق طلال ترامب ومناصريه حيث
ابدى ترامب شكوكه بخصوص شرعيه الانتخابات
النصفيه في ولايه تنسلفانيا
لا نحن نعيد الكره مره اخرى الانتخابات
المزوره المثير في الموضوع هو ان حتى دم
من المرشحين هذا وحذوى ترامب في التشكيك
في النتائج المحتمله وفقا لدراسه ان
نشرتها نيويورك اكدت ان مواقف عدد من
الجمهوريين الذين يترشحون في ولايات
رئيسيه مثل الولايات السلبيات تشكك من
الان في نزاهه عمليه التصوير وهو ما قد
يضر بالعمليه ديمقراطيه كما ترى الصحيح
وفي ارتباطن بولايه فيصل بينيا فان
الانظار ستكون مركزه عليها بشكل كبير خلال
الانتخابات المقبله بالنظر الى الخصوصيه
التي تحظى بها وما يؤكد ذلك هو قيام ثلاثه
رؤساء بالمشاركه في الحملات الانتخابيه
للولايات اليوم الاخير قبل الانتخابات
واجتمع الرئيس الحالي وبايدر مع سلفه
باراك اوباما وكلاهما من الحزب الديمقراطي
في تجمع الانتخابي في الولايه في المقابل
شركه ترامب في تجمع لصالح الحزب الجمهوري
والصراع المحتدم ياتي لكونها قادره على
تحديد من سيتحكم بالمجلس الشيوخ الامريكي
الذي تتعادل فيه المقاعد حاليا ب 50 مقعدا
لكل الحزبين الديمقراطي والجمله
ناديه البلبيسي معنى مباشره من واشنطن
ناديه اهلا بك معنا لماذا الحديث عن تزوير
الانتخابات في ولايه بنسلفانيا بالذات
من الان في حال عدم فوز المرشحين الذين
دعمهم ومنهم طبعا المرشح لمنصب مجلس
الشيوخ ميمت اوز وهو طبيب من اصل تركي
البعض يراه غير مؤهل اصلا لم يكن يعيش في
ولايه بنت سلفانيا ينتقل من نيويورك الى
رئيس بعدين كان يسخر منه قال باننا سكن في
بنت سلوفينيا اكثر من وانا تركب سفينه
وكان عمري عشر سنوات وبالتالي موضوع
التشكيك بالنسبه للجمهوريه هو فقط ينطبق
على مؤيد الرئيس ترامب بمعنى التشيك ليس
حتى بالشكل المطلق بما انا انه اذا فازوا
هم ليش لن يكون هناك همم ربما فساد في
العمليه الانتخابيه ولا تلاعب واذا لم
يفوزوا همم ساعتها يقول ترامب بان هناك
تشكيك وبانها الانتخابات
عن تصوير الانتخابات مره اخرى ويجد له
يعني مؤيدين كذلك هذا في همم اكبر
الديمقراطيات في العالم يعني ماذا تركوا
لي الديمقراطيه الاخرى حول العالم
التواصل الاجتماعي كان هناك التدخل في
السابق من دول اجنبيه مثل روسيا اتهمت
بانها حاولت التلاعب في الانتخابات
الامريكيه لصالح الرئيس ترامب والى اخره
وبالتالي عندما يكون هناك خلط ما بين
الحقيقه وبين المعلومات المدله البعض يلجا
الى المعلومات المظله وهناك الكثير من
الامثله همم كل يوم في تقريبا هو كما تعرف
الانسان جدا في عالم السوشل ميليا ان يكون
هناك همم ربما تزييف الفيديو معين تركيب
الاسوار معينه تحميل اقوال الرئيس نفسه
حتى رغم انه لا يقولها
خطير جدا يعني الامر ليس صحيح نحن نتحدث
من باب ربما تساؤل او التعجب الطريف ولكن
المساله خطيره بالفعل يعني راينا ما حدث
في احدث الكابتل بعد ما قال لم يعترف
ترامب بنتيجه الانتخابات التي خسرها كان
هناك انصار له اقتحموا اكبر المؤسسات
الديمقراطيه في
ما واشنطن هذه المره في هذه الانتخابات
النصفيه هل يعني سنشاهد مشاهد مماثله
[موسيقى]
يعني يتنبا مسبقا اذا كان هناك احداث عنف
ام لا لكن هناك اجواء تطبيقات الانتخابات
اا تعطينا بعض المؤشرات بان هناك اي
انقسام هناك استقطاب دون ان شك يعني وبشكل
عام اكيد يعني موضوع العنف ومرافق خصوصا
منذ عهد الرئيس ترامب حتى الان حاله
الانقسام الواضحه في الولايات المتحده لكن
بالنهايه سنرى غدا طبعا الذي سيحسن هذه
الانتخابات هم المجموعه المتردده حتى الان
اريد ان اذكر على فكره همم بان هناك 41
مليون امريكي صوت ومبكرا في الانتخابات عن
طريق البريد وبالتالي حتى الرسائل التي
ركز عليها رئيس العنوان الاساسي
الديمقراطيه في خطر يعني تعقيبا عاما
ذكرته قبل قليل صهيب هذا ما يركز عليه
البيت الابيض وما يقوله الديمقراطيون بان
نفهم بان هناك قضايا مصيريه مثل الاقتصاد
والارتفاع الغير مسبوق للاسعار المواد
الاساسيه كماليه والمحروقات والتضخم
الاخيره لكن بالنهايه الاسس التي قامت
عليها اكبر ديمقراطيات الغربيه وهي
الولايات المتحده تكون قد تكون مهدده في
هذه الانتخابات بسبب مواد الاسباب التي
شرحتها قبل قليل وهو ان هناك التشكيك في
عمليه النزاهه لهذه الانتخابات وسهل جدا
بالنسبه لبعض الاشخاص الذين يؤمنون يؤمنون
بنظريه المؤامره ان يروا بالفعل بانه هذه
الانتخابات همم قد تكون مزوره لكن هي
مزوره فقط اريد ان اركز على هذا النقطه
اذا خسر مرشح والترام بيعتبروها مزوره الى
فازوا يعتبرها
واشنطن العاصمه شكرا جزيلا
[موسيقى]
وعلى ذكرى وسائل التواصل لم يكتب
التواصل الاجتماعيه تويتر
يمنع توغل اي من الحسبين في الحكم وقال
ماسك انه يفضل ان يسيطر الجمهوريون على
الرئيس الحالي
[موسيقى]
وبعد قليل في اخبار الساعه القاره العجوز
التي عرفناها بطقسها البارد تموت حرا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اكد ولي العهد السعودي
الامير محمد بن سلمان حرص المملكه على
استقرار السودان ودعم التعاون والشراكه
بين البلدين في كثره المجردات وذلك خلال
لقاء الجماعه
السوداني عبد الفتاح البرهان على هامشي
قمه الشرق الاوسط الاخضر في شرم الشيخ
واشار الامير محمد بن سلمان الى انه سيتم
ضخ ثلاثه مليار دولار ضمن خطب صندوق
استثمارات العامه في السودان
[موسيقى]
افادى مراسل العربيه نقلا عن مصادر امينه
العراقيه بغتيلي شخص امريكي يدعى ستيفن
ادوارد رول وسط العاصمه بغداد على ايدي
مسلحين مجهولين واضافات المصادر الامنيه
ان عمليه الاغتيال وقعت في شارع الصناعه
بمنطقه الكراده بينما كانت رول يتجول بشكل
منفرد بواسطه سياره بيضاء ذات دفع رباعي
[موسيقى]
حيث بدانا ننهي المناخ واثره الكارثيه
التي بدات تظهر على كل بقاع الارض اوروبا
مثلا التي عرفت بطقسها البارد شاهدت في
السنوات الاخيره موجات حرا غير مسبوقه
منظمه الصحه العالميه اعلنت اليوم ان ما
لا يقل عن 15,000 شخص لقى وحدفه في اوروبا
بسبب الطقس الحار في عام 2022 حتى الان
وكانت اسبانيا والمانيا من بين الدول اكثر
تضررا جراء ارتفاع درجات الحراره الناجمه
عن التغير المناخي
[موسيقى]
هذه الساعه انتهت اليكم تذكيرا بابرز
اخبارها من قمه المناخ تحذيرات من هلاك
البشر ومبادرات لانقاذ الارض والسعوديه
تخصص 2.5 مليار دولار لشرق الاوسط اخضر
في اول مقابله له مع قناه عربيه
في اوكرانيا الحرب كر وفر والمفاوضات مد
وجزر روسيا تتهم كياب برفض الحوار
والاخيره تنفي ولكن بشروط
قبل الاقتراع والفرز الجمهوريون يشككون في
نتائج الانتخابات النصفيه وحكام الولايات
يضعون خططا استباق
كانت هذه اخبار ساعه لهذا الاثنين شكرا
لكم على المشاهده المزيد دائما على
العربيه
[موسيقى]